bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
philico l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique on passe tout de
suite aux grandes lignes de l'émission
les agriculteurs mobilisés de nombreux
axes routiers ont été bloqués ce matin
autour de Paris dans les Yvelines la N10
et line 12 les manifestants dénoncent
une surfiscalisation et la
redistribution des aides européennes en
faveur de l'élevage
les circuits courts vous connaissez le
manger local n'est pas nouveau mais
quand il s'agit de vaches écossaises qui
protège la faune et la flore du parc de
la Vallée de Chevreuse cela devient tout
de suite plus original explication dans
notre dossier de la semaine et puis à
l'occasion de la Semaine pour l'emploi
des personnes handicapées nous recevons
sur ce plateau Christian rose bonsoir
vous êtes président de Cap Emploi
Yvelines ne reviendront donc quelques
minutes sur la situation et sur votre
action à tout à l'heure on passe avant
cela à l'actualité économique de la
semaine
on le disait les agriculteurs sont
mobilisés ils dénoncent une
surfiscalisation et la redistribution
des aides européennes en faveur de
l'élevage leur moyen d'action les
blocages routiers en Île-de-France 7
points de blocage ce matin dont trois
rien que dans les Yvelines à hauteur des
pônes vers menthe mais aussi sur ces
images sur la nationale 10 entre
Rambouillet et trappes et sur la
nationale 12 on écoute les explications
de Christophe Le rebours membres du
syndicat agricole fdcf sea pardon au
micro de Wilfried Richie
l'agriculture céréalière en France est
un vecteur économique extrêmement
important et Monsieur le folle n'en
tient pas compte demain si nous vivons
plus de notre métier c'est tout le
secteur amont et aval de l'économie
française qui va s'écrouler au niveau de
du milieu agricole voilà c'est très
simple comme message et c'est un message
qu'il faut absolument que les gens
arrivent à comprendre
et un accident mortel assez
malheureusement produit en marge des
barrages des tracteurs et de camions
dans le Val-d'Oise sur la Francilienne
un pompier qui se rendait à son travail
a été tué dans une collision le barrage
du Val d'Oise a tout de suite été levé
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage des
personnes handicapées atteint 20% deux
fois plus que la moyenne nationale la
Semaine pour l'emploi des personnes
handicapées cherchent à cherchent pardon
à changer cette donnée des événements
ont lieu partout en France à 50 ans en
Yvelines un forum emploi était organisé
mardi matin des images de Patrick
Jacques Sud
à Guyancourt des centaines de personnes
se pressaient ce mardi à ce forum de
l'emploi un forum ouvert exclusivement
aux travailleurs handicapés en 2012 on
en comptabilisé 6400 dans le département
handicapés physiques en fauteuil sourd
muet malvoyants ou déficients mentaux
ici pour une fois on oublie leur
handicap pour s'intéresser à leurs
compétences on sent que les gens sont
réceptifs je pense qu'ils sont formés
par rapport au handicap aussi dans leur
propre entreprise donc ils ont pas le
même regard des structures de travail
spécialisées existent mais la majorité
d'entre eux 85% peuvent travailler dans
le circuit classique et pourtant les
recruteurs restent frileux leur taux de
chômage est deux fois supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
il faut dire skier on est isolé partout
ici Abdelkader peut aller à la rencontre
des 45 exposants et tenter sa chance en
face à face auprès de recruteurs pour
faciliter leur venue un véhicule
spécialisé fait la navette gratuitement
vers la gare et sont présentes pour les
sourds et muets à ce stand on s'occupe
également de les conseiller en images
alors là vous êtes à l'atelier
colorimétrie donc la colorimétrie c'est
encore une fois donc c'est la découverte
des couleurs qui vont vous mettre en
valeur se mettre en valeur et se sentir
en confiance mais ce genre d'événements
ne règle pas tout on se rend compte que
globalement le public des personnes en
situation de handicap en recherche
d'emploi sont des personnes qui n'ont
pas encore un niveau de qualification
forcément totalement en adéquation avec
les postes qu'on peut proposer pour les
CDI en tout cas c'est beaucoup des
postes en ingénieur bac + 5 plutôt
techniques et donc du coup c'est vrai
que ça limite un petit peu si les
mentalités changent petit à petit et que
l'on retrouve aujourd'hui des personnes
handicapées à la place des recruteurs il
reste encore du chemin pour atteindre
l'équité
14e édition de la Semaine école
entreprise dans les Yvelines une semaine
initié par le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale jusqu'au 22 novembre les
entreprises ouvrent leurs portes aux
enseignants et aux écoliers mercredi
l'entreprise Volvo à Trappes accueillait
des collégiens un reportage réalisé avec
Jonathan Wilman
ces élèves de 3e du Lycée Henri Matisse
à trappe ont quitté ce mercredi leur
salle de classe à la place d'un cours
théorique ils ont visité l'entreprise
Volvo dans un premier temps une
explication de l'activité de la société
et de ses métiers principalement dans le
domaine de la maintenance
deuxième étape l'atelier ou les
techniciens du groupe s'occupent de
réparer ou d'entretenir ces gros engins
de travaux publics un cours pas comme
les autres et le concept semble
intéresser les élèves ce qui est bien ce
qu'on découvre des métiers et ça nous
aide plus tard quoi pour notre avenir et
c'est intéressant parce que on est dans
une troisième découverte pro donc comme
ça on découvre plein de métiers et je
trouve ça intéressant malgré quelques
flocons les élèves les plus intéressés
visitent le parc des machines certains
découvrent ici de nouvelles perspectives
d'avenir je vois que Volvo avaient une
marque avec des engins et je connaissais
que les voitures pour l'instant j'ai
envie de faire un mécanicien auto
et peut-être que plus tard mécanicien de
engin comme ça objectif atteint pour
l'entreprise car son activité principale
la maintenance TP est trop souvent
méconnu du grand public nous on fait ces
actions là parce qu'on a besoin de
remplir nos filières on a vraiment un
manque de technicien
quand on en cherche des fois on met 6
mois à trouver un bon technicien un
secteur qui recrute et qui propose aux
débutants un salaire de base de 1700
euros
et ce matin des étudiants de
l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines recevait des acteurs du monde
professionnel lors d'ateliers
thématiques ils ont pu échanger sur le
management des âges en entreprise et
l'entrée des jeunes dans le monde du
travail un succès de nombreux
entreprises institutions locales
européen répondu présente comme nous
l'explique l'animateur de cette matinée
j'étais très surpris de voir à quel
point de chefs d'entreprise ce sont
développées déplacés et des intervenants
qui viennent d'institutions importantes
de la CGPME du Medef et des autres donc
c'est dire l'intérêt qui porte à cette
nouvelle génération et elle est
nécessaire adéquation entre ce que
produit comme l'université et ce
qu'attend l'entreprise
et chaque groupe de réflexion ensuite
rapporté les grandes lignes de leurs
débat lors d'une plénière l'enjeu était
aussi de faire prendre conscience de
l'intérêt du management
intergénérationnel
le but il reste encore largement
approuvé que quand on arrive à combiner
des générations dans des équipes ça
favorise la créativité voir l'innovation
ça permet à l'entreprise de développer
des champs des pratiques des services
qui lui permettent de se développer de
gagner en performance il faut que c'est
une réponse à un enjeu de business
l'entreprise AKKA Technologies a
remporté le grand prix national de
l'ingénierie 2013 avec son prototype
link and go il s'agit d'une voiture
électrique et automatique ce prix est
remis par le ministère du redressement
productif et c'est la première fois
qu'un projet d'ingénierie prime sur les
projets de construction le secret pour
le chef de projet mécanique et design il
s'agit de mixer les différents métiers
et de ne pas se donner de limites
de créer ce véhicule autonome bimode
avec des innovations technologiques
telles que le by wire l'ensemble des
courants qui sont au volant c'est c'est
des choses qui qu'on en parle au
constructeur on a il y a une vraie de
leur part il y a une vraie admiration de
dire vous l'avez fait et de leur propre
aveu ils disent on n'aurait pas pu le
faire nous en interne parce que les
process parce que les contraintes
derrière qui suivent et qui qui sont pas
les notes donc je dirais on a on a une
certaine facilité à être en rupture par
rapport à eux parce qu'on n'a pas le
même environnement de travail donc je
dirais qu'on apporte cette voilà cette
fraîcheur un petit peu et cette rapidité
de mise en œuvre pour rappeler que le
projet était fait en 14 mois
à la rentrée 2015 à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux devrait s'ouvrir
à quelques pas du vélo de Rome une
nouvelle école l'ESTACA une école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans le domaine
des transports leur est encore au
chantier un reportage de Catherine
zulato et Anthony Rech un arbre guise de
première pierre le chantier de l'ESTACA
Montigny-le-Bretonneux officiellement
lancé ici tout près du vélo Drôme
ouvrira donc à la rentrée 2015 une école
d'ingénieurs dédiée au domaine des
transports aéronautique automobile
spatiale ou ferroviaire et pour se faire
sur une tablette l'image du futur
bâtiment en réalité augmentée on s'y
croirait sa révolutionne vraiment la
l'approche qu'on peut avoir d'un
bâtiment on se base plus sur un plan
grâce à cette technologie pas et puis je
suis sur un plan mais on peut vraiment
augmenter ce plan et le voir directement
le bâtiment d'où le côté un peu
révolutionnaire la forme du bâtiment qui
est cintrée avec notamment ses profils
en façade et ses dessins de d'ouverture
veut exprimer cette cette je dirais
cette ce mouvement permanent sur le
bâtiment l'école va donc quitter ses
locaux de Levallois
périple choix stratégique pour se
rapprocher des sociétés d'ingénierie et
des partenaires académiques comme
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
et travailler sur les solutions de
transport de demain c'est à tout ce qui
est conduite automatisée et imaginez le
matin vous travaillez sur Paris vous
habitez
un petit peu loin et bien vous montez
dans votre voiture vous lâchez le volant
sur l'autoroute vous pouvez traiter vos
mails travailler et votre voiture est
complètement prise en charge par
l'infrastructure les transports de
demain c'est aussi une autre façon de
penser la mobilité et c'est probablement
moins de voitures des véhicules partagés
c'est vraiment un secteur porteur en
plus on a des on a la chance d'être en
relation très direct avec les
partenaires industriels quasiment tous
nos professeurs sont détachés de
l'industrie ou un travail d'ingénieur à
côté et viennent donner quelques heures
de cours dans leur spécialité l'école
accueillera la première année un peu
plus de 1000 étudiants pour une capacité
totale de 1500 un chantier à hauteur de
50 millions d'euros
carrés privés ouest la outlet de luxe
qui devrait qui devait prendre la place
de Skywest à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ne
verra jamais le jour la société amerson
nous a indiqué qu'elle souhaiterait
créer un centre commercial familial
relié à l'actuel galerie marchande toute
proche les projets devraient être
dévoilés 2014 pour le moment il ne reste
qu'une dizaine de commerces plus
d'explications dans le 7 8 de demain
et puis qui a en France mise en examen
on vous parlait la semaine dernière
d'une énième perquisition aussi siège de
l'entreprise à Plaisir mardi la société
en tant que personne morale mais aussi
le PDG le directeur financier et
l'ancien directeur général ont été mis
en examen suite à une information
judiciaire ouverte en avril 2012 ils
sont accusés d'avoir espionné leur
salarié
IKEA est donc soumis un contrôle
judiciaire et doit payer une caution de
500.000 euros
pour finir les communes ayant contracté
des emprunts toxiques comme Rambouillet
et plaisir vont pouvoir souffler un fond
de soutien en faveur des collectivités
locales créées en juin vient d'être
validé il permettra de distribuer 100
millions d'euros par an pendant 15 ans
se font devrait être abondés par moitié
par l'État par moitié par les banques
et maintenant tant de passer à
l'entretien
c'est la Semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées chaque année c'est
le moyen de sensibiliser sensibiliser
oui à une inégalité qui persiste le taux
de chômage des travailleurs handicapés
et deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
française sur notre plateau ne recevons
Christian rose bonsoir le directeur de
Cap Emploi Yvelines alors un mot pour
débuter sur Cap emploi c'est un réseau
d'organismes de placement spécialisés
votre but finalement c'est de faciliter
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes handicapées
le réseau est constitué de 103
structures en France donc une seule dans
les Yvelines et nous existons depuis
1995 et donc effectivement nous sommes
en charge de l'accompagnement renforcer
des travailleurs handicapés qui nous
sont orientés par la MDPH Pôle emploi et
voilà mission de service public financé
par la Gifi et le FIP voilà qui sont les
deux grands fonds qui gèrent et
récoltent voilà très bien alors lors de
cette semaine de sensibilisation donc on
l'a vu il y a quelques minutes s'il y
avait un forum pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées vous étiez
présents il y avait un stand
nous sommes co-organisateur avec la
communauté d'agglomérations et puis Pôle
Emploi bien évidemment sur ces semaines
sur cette semaine du handicap et chaque
année nous sommes bien évidemment
présents à ce forum
un sacré succès c'est
chaque année effectivement de forums se
tiennent dans les Yvelines le principal
étant effectivement sur Saint-Quentin et
puis l'autre étant ce matin d'ailleurs
même au Mureaux voilà
180 personnes je dirais aux Mureaux
Saint-Quentin j'ai pas encore les
retours mais effectivement une
fréquentation assez forte toujours des
travailleurs handicapés effectivement et
nombre d'entreprises étaient présentes y
compris des grands groupes qui sont sur
le secteur
vous avez mis en place d'autres
événements durant cette semaine vous
pouvez nous en dire un mot
les événements sont en direction de
l'ouverture des des portes en fait des
entreprises aux personnes c'est
l'occasion effectivement des rencontres
des mises en situation de la découverte
en fait de l'entreprise donc on a
proposé des stages avec avec des grands
groupes effectivement qui se prêtent
volontiers ce type d'événements et donc
peuvent ainsi communiquer et
sensibilisés en interne le personnel
donc c'est l'action un jour amitié en
action c'est une action nationale mais
qu'on élargit un peu sur une semaine
pratiquement sur des grands groupes
voilà il y a un après cette semaine pour
ces personnes handicapées certaines
arrivent à regagner le marché de
l'emploi c'est une découverte il y a
aucune embauche à la clé c'est
clairement dit et affiché dès le départ
mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement l'ensemble des
entreprises contribuent à cette à cette
semaine et donc c'est un des moyens
parmi d'autres effectivement une
première étape c'est ça alors dans le
département la Maison départementale des
personnes handicapées la MDPH vous en
parliez nous a indiqué que 6400
personnes avaient été reconnues
travaillées handicapés en 2012 mais
finalement être travailleur handicapé ça
veut dire pas mal de choses on pense
tout de suite à une personne en fauteuil
roulant mais c'est pas forcément la
majorité non les personnes en fauteuil
roulant c'est vraiment la 2% de la
population on est à peu près 50% des
personnes qui ont effectivement une
déficience motrice donc une difficulté
de santé liée avec une mobilité et le
reste effectivement des handicaps
sensoriels et puis maladie invalidantes
et puis la troisième catégorie étant le
maladies psychique à peu près une 15% de
la population voilà donc le handicap
moteur ne se résume pas à la personne en
fauteuil roulant ça c'est bien clair le
problème majeur finalement ce serait des
problèmes de dos des problèmes de dos
des problèmes de mobilité effectivement
liés à des accidents de vie des
accidents du travail des maladies
invalidantes un certain nombre de
situations où les personnes ne peuvent
plus rester en emploi et donc sont
orientés vers nous pour une reconversion
professionnelle
alors justement parking sont-elles
orientées et combien de personnes à peu
près vous suivez alors donc nous suivons
à peu près 3000 personnes au 31 12 de
l'année c'est 2400 dossiers ouverts à
peu près 700 personnes sont orientées
par Pôle emploi dans le cadre d'une
convention de co-traitance orientation
donc par les conseillers Pôle emploi
pour cet accompagnement renforcé le
reste étant effectivement des personnes
qui nous sont orientés par la MDPH donc
à peu près 1000 à 1200 nouvelles
personnes accompagnées par an sur les
3000 et quelques personnes pour
lesquelles on sert un service si je puis
dire dans l'année voilà
alors comment vous vous travaillez
justement avec Pôle Emploi comment ils
peuvent être amenés jusqu'à vous est-ce
que vous avez aussi d'autres tractions
ensemble alors nous avons des actions
effectivement en parallèles avec des
orientations donc sur des informations
collectives sur des formations qui nous
sont proposées et que on oriente donc
nos travailleurs handicapés nous avons
aussi bien sûr les formations qui sont
financées par la Gifi et ou par le FIP
sachant que ces deux fonds contribuent
bien évidemment à l'orientation et à la
formation des personnes on l'a vu ça a
été dit dans le reportage un très grand
nombre malheureusement ont des
compétences qui ne sont pas les
compétences requises par ces grands
groupes et donc il y a nécessité
effectivement de former ces cette
population c'est à peu près 75 à 80% qui
sont d'un niveau 5 donc c'est à dire
bepcap et donc bien évidemment et
surtout sur le secteur de 50 ans en
Yvelines les entreprises
qui viennent effectivement du monde de
du bâtiment
je dis souvent des accidents des gens
qui sont fatigués usés par ce type de
d'emploi on en parle beaucoup
en ce moment et donc effectivement la
pénibilité et donc ce sont ce type de de
personnes qui n'ont pas eu la chance de
suivre des formations par le passé et
donc la population est effectivement
d'âge plutôt avancé je dirais même 15%
de seniors de plus de 55 ans et donc
c'est le résultat en fait de toute une
carrière professionnelle qui fait qu'ils
sont inapte à leur poste ni plus ni
moins vous leur proposez en fait des
solutions du coup pour donc on les prend
en charge effectivement pour une
réorientation une définition d'un projet
éventuellement une montée en compétences
par des formations on transfère de
compétences c'est-à-dire que les
personnes ont des compétences qu'on
essaye bien évidemment d'utiliser pour
leur proposer un nouvel emploi et donc
nous les proposons et les orientons vers
les entreprises dès lors que on estime
qu'ils sont prêts effectivement à
regagner le marché de l'emploi
est-ce que le problème c'est seulement
finalement ce manque de formation est-ce
que les entreprises sont assez ouvertes
alors écoutez depuis la loi de 2005 et
notamment effectivement les obligations
qui sont les leurs sachant
que on a effectivement une attitude
beaucoup plus ouverte aujourd'hui on est
quand même qu'à 3 % sur le secteur privé
le secteur public est un peu plus ouvert
on est à 4,5 à voir 5% dans les Yvelines
j'ai pas les chiffres précis mais
aujourd'hui avec la mobilisation qui est
celle
de la semaine du handicap enfin de
l'ensemble des entreprises effectivement
on a quand même un certain nombre
d'entreprises
contributrices auprès du fond mais qui
sont désireuses effectivement
d'embaucher dans ce cadre-là je dis pas
que les choses sont acquises puisqu'il y
a 4500 demandeurs d'emploi aujourd'hui
dans les Yvelines reconnues travaillant
handicapés qui sont au chômage on a une
très forte hausse en 2013 de plus 17%
des demandeurs d'emploi mais je dirais
et la preuve en est le reportage a été
diffusé il y a quand même une volonté
forte des entreprises aujourd'hui de
satisfaire leur obligation et c'est le
point positif et donc des aménagements
assez simples peuvent être réalisés
finir juste sur sur un point sur les
établissements
spécialisés on va dire il y a 85 % des
travailleurs handicapés donc qui
travaillent finalement au milieu
ordinaire voilà 15% dans le secteur
protégé voilà par exemple les actes de
Trappes nous indiquer qu'il y a une
liste d'attente de 80 à 100 personnes
est-ce qu'il y a un manque finalement
aussi ça peut être aussi un autre
problème évidemment puisque la plupart
des personnes aussi maintenant sont
désireuses de pouvoir regagner le marché
de l'emploi et donc la MDPH les oriente
soit sur le marché ordinaire soit sur le
marché protégés le milieu protégé pardon
et donc il y a effectivement une liste
détente parce que le nombre de places en
établissement les services d'aide par le
travail fait défaut bien qui ait des
efforts considèrent à fait par les
pouvoirs publics et dans le département
des Yvelines en particulier mais aussi
ne m'étonne pas sont encore sont encore
importants
en tout cas pour nous en parler on passe
maintenant au dossier de la semaine
des vaches élevées dans la vallée de
Chevreuse qui finissent au menu des
auberges des alentours un bel exemple de
circuits courts mais le projet proposé
par le parc naturel est un peu plus
original qu'il n'y paraît les vaches
sont écossaises et avant de nourrir
l'homme elle protège la faune et la
flore du parc explication en images un
sujet réalisé avec Elodie moine Patrick
et Jacques de Dixmude et Jonathan
Willmann
dans ce restaurant de la Vallée de
Chevreuse depuis ce week-end les clients
se pressent pour goûter au bœuf préparé
par Jean-Louis un bœuf élevé à quelques
kilomètres de là et que l'on apprécie
particulièrement pour son goût le goût
de la viande
qui est
beaucoup prononcé sur la vallée de
Chevreuse parce que ce sont des bêtes
qui mangent dans les dans les marécages
un lieu hostile pour les vaches
françaises mais qui fait le bonheur de
ses buffs et vaches aux poils longs
originaires d'Écosse plus petites et
moins lourdes elle s'y déplace
facilement et ils mangent toutes les
espèces petits arbres compris cette
Highland Cattle littéralement cheptel
écossais appartient au parc naturel de
la vallée de Chevreuse car leur présence
a un intérêt écologique majeur pour nous
il s'agissait d'essayer d'expérimenter
pour voir avec quelle race on pouvait
entretenir ces milieux car avec la
déprise pastorale en fait
progressivement c'est la forêt qui
s'installe on a un stade de friche
arbustive puis de forêt donc il y avait
vraiment une perte de biodiversité qui
était liée à l'abandon de ces prairies
et la nécessité pour nous de remettre de
la gestion pastorale sur ces espaces ces
espaces délaissés par les agriculteurs
était à l'abandon depuis les années 60
pourtant l'humidité et le climat ont
permis le développement d'une faune et
d'une flore spécifique à la moyenne
montagne son action de ces vaches
écossaises ces espèces protégées
auraient déjà laissé place à la forêt
les premières vaches ont été achetées en
1994 depuis un cheptel reproducteur
fournit deux vos parents le couple vit
non loin de là à
châteauforte de prairie qui est d'à peu
près 10 hectares donc pour maintenir les
plantes rares on a l'obligation de pas
dépasser à un certain nombre d'animaux
sur une surface donnée 12 bovins maximum
peuvent vivre ensemble quand il y a
surplus les bœufs sont envoyés à
l'abattoir un moyen également
d'équilibrer les dépenses cette année
trois auberges des environs ont choisi
de les proposer à leur menu l'Auberge de
l'Artoire a reçu la semaine dernière une
carcasse entière Jean-Louis s'est chargé
de la réception mais aussi de la découpe
des différentes pièces il s'attaque ici
au collier et apprécie cet arrivage
local
dans les frigos n'importe où
et puis bon ça fait plaisir de
travailler de la belle viande Jean-Louis
retrouve les joies de son premier métier
bouché l'opération lui permet d'acheter
locale le reste de l'année il propose
généralement de la viande hollandaise
dont la qualité est plus constante au
fil des mois que le bœuf français
classique
nous on préférerait acheter plus
français mais c'est une question de
qualité et de prix on pourrait pas
proposer
la viande à notre carte ou dans nos
menus avec de la viande française on ne
pourrait pas appliquer ces prix là c'est
pris avoisine et les 25 euros le plats
nous retrouvons Jean-Louis en cuisine le
bœuf écossais est désormais sur la carte
et les premiers clients du jour arrivent
l'année dernière j'avais fait un demi
soyez du succès cette année je fais une
bête entière cette année il espère
pouvoir satisfaire tout le monde allez
il est temps d'amener les plats en salle
et de laisser les clients déguster ce
couple d'ivelinois ne semble pas déçu et
autant faire travailler les producteurs
locaux déjà puis aussi d'où elle vient
surtout on connaît l'origine on en est
sûr du goût et de la qualité seul point
noir de ce circuit court la battage en
Île-de-France il n'existe plus aucun
abattoir il faut désormais se rendre
dans l'Orne pas encore du 100% local
il y a noté tout de même qu'un atelier
de découpe devrait ouvrir l'année
prochaine à Rambouillet c'est la fin de
ce filetco merci de nous avoir suivis
bonne soirée et à la semaine prochaine